for decades The Adventures of Monkey D
Luffy and the straw hat Pirates have
thrilled and Enchanted readers and
viewers across the globe turning such a
beloved and long-running
action-adventure series into game form
has proven to be quite a challenge with
many developers stepping up over the
years to try and gamify the magic that's
made to the one-piece anime and manga
such a success often to mixed results
one piece Odyssey is the latest such
attempt and it takes the approach of
transforming one piece's dramatic
battles into a turn-based RPG while it
does a solid job of getting the look and
mood of the series down one piece
Odyssey unfortunately offers little more
than a very basic RPG Adventure
foreign
the game opens with the straw hat gang
stranded on the mysterious island of
waffled their ship Thousand Sunny lies
in a wreck nearby and with no obvious
way to repair it the gang sets out
exploring this wild New World a strange
young girl named Lim emerges and fearful
of the Pirates she removes all of the
crew's strengths and special powers with
the help of audio a rather suspicious
adventurer who calls the island his home
the straw hats set out to recover their
powers learn the secrets of Wofford
Island and escape to Journey another day
along the way they'll also be able to
relive the Great Adventures of the past
the story shifts its focus from getting
off of Wofford Islands to getting
everyone's full power back with the aid
of Island residents Lim and audio fairly
quickly and that remains the Crux of the
story for quite some time recovering
Powers means finding special cubes
scattered across the island and held by
the mighty colossi fully restoring the
powers contained in the cubes is a
rather involved process Lim must send
the crew to a dream world called Memoria
where they relive some of the most
important events of their lives in other
words they Venture into Recreations of
past story arcs from the one-piece anime
and manga though events within them
unfold differently the justification is
that memories are unreliable only by
fully reliving these events in Memoria
and in some cases venturing even further
into strange sub worlds can the crew
restore what they've lost one piece
odyssey's narrative is sadly rather
disappointing over its lifespan one
piece has given fans many wonderful
memorable stories and created a
fascinating World filled with law and
Intrigue the idea of playing through an
original story packed with action and
adventure set in the one piece world as
an RPG is a very exciting one but
Odyssey mostly excuse that potential in
favor of revisiting past story arcs in
Memoria so the straw hats can recover
their powers these Journeys into the
past comprise the bulk of the 30 to 40
hour playtime while there are some
thoughtfully portrayed interactions from
the present day crew as they revisit
places and people from the past setting
the game in dream Universe stories that
have already resolved even if they play
out differently robs them of their drama
and impact the conclusions are already
known the stakes don't feel compelling
and the characters are simply doing
what's needed to reach the inevitable
finale we've seen before it doesn't help
that there's a lot of fetch Quest and
NPC hunting style padding present either
from the outset one piece Odyssey does a
fantastic job of capturing the look and
feel of the manga the character models
look vibrant and their animations and
expressions nail the goofy slapstick
kineticism that defines one piece's
style of action and character art combat
animations are particularly well done
with Luffy's rubber limbed smackdowns
usopp's comical sniper techniques and
Robin's strangely sensuous multi-limmed
combat submission strikes look dynamic
in a way that feels authentic to the
source material the interactions between
the characters are also in line with
what fans of the series have come to
expect the straw hats banter and bicker
with each other as you explore the
various environments adding a good dose
of charm to the proceedings and letting
the personalities that many have come to
love truly shine through
while exploring characters can swap in
and use their unique abilities provided
they've recovered them to get through
obstacles sling across gaps and find
hidden items like cooking ingredients
each character has one or more unique
field abilities Luffy construction
grapple Zoro can cut through certain
barriers usop can shoot at specific
targets and so on while this adds some
enjoyable variety and Discovery to field
navigation the frequent needs to
interrupt exploration to go into a sub
menu and choose a new leader to use
their skills is a bit of an annoyance
still the solid visual presentation and
the constant crew chatter combined with
all the exploration abilities make
Fields travel enjoyable enough to offset
the inconvenience of swapping when it
comes to combat however things start to
slip battles are presented in a
traditional turn-based format though
unlike many turn-based games characters
can act in any order and be freely
swapped in and out without penalty
during your phase giving you a very
strong combat Advantage off the bat when
you're choosing which foes to Target
there's a fire emblem style rock paper
scissor system in play where characters
are affiliated with one of three combat
types that grants damage advantages and
disadvantages over other types Power
Beats speed speed beats technique
technique beats power there's also an
added twist where upon battle
commencement characters are randomly
assigned to different areas restructing
which enemies they can't attack you
can't Target enemies outside of your
area with normal attacks unless all foes
in your area are ko'd but depending on
the character and abilities you may be
able to affect enemies in another area
with a special technique this sounds
like a neat Twist on paper but in
practice the targeting restrictions
simply prove irritating necessitating
you either spends TP to attack enemies
out of your area or Shuffle everyone
around the presentation of the battles
also makes it difficult to tell at a
glance how many enemies there are and
which zone they're in leading to
targeting mistakes and resulting
annoyances it's not a terrible combat
engine but it's easily exploitable to
the points that it becomes unengaging
and at worst an annoying Interruption
the freedom to take turns in any order
and swap in characters on a whim makes
it a cinch to stack your combat party
full of characters with advantages over
the opponent placing crew exactly where
they're needed to mow enemies down and
heal allies quickly you can also set up
powerful Bond Arts that require specific
team members to be on the field without
much hassle further trivializing many
combat scenarios some side quests such
as the memory link quests that unlock
Bond Arts restrict the crew members you
can use which makes things more
interesting but these quests are
woefully short also one piece Odyssey
hands out copious amounts of XP for
completing a very simple random
challenges like beats this enemy in one
turn so you level up quickly if you're
engaging in combat with even a moderate
degree of frequency leveling up grants
stat boosts only as you only acquire
combat techniques after reaching set
points in the story but those quickly
accumulating stats can make a huge
difference even if the overall character
growth is rather limited eventually it
can get to the point where even the
character type system becomes mostly
irrelevant
fundamentally one piece Odyssey isn't a
bad RPG just a very generic one that
strives to do little more than tick off
all the check boxes of what players
expect from the genre side quests
crafting cooking fan service and so on
attaching the one-piece license to it
results in expectations that are only
partially met while the straw hats are
as delightful as ever to be around the
story they found themselves stuck in is
not ultimately the greatest sin of One
Piece Odyssey is wasted potential
something it shares with many of the
other video game adaptations of the
franchise
[Music]
thank you